♪ ♪
>> KIRSTJEN NIELSEN IS A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
GO TO WORK FOR DONALD TRUMP.
HE IS A GREATER PREDATION
KILLER.
HERE'S THIS WOMAN WHO WAS A
REASONABLY ADMIRED BUREAUCRAT,
AND FOR THE REST OF HER LIFE,
FOR THE REST OF HER LIFE PEOPLE
WILL LOOK AT HER AND THINK, THAT
IS THE WOMAN WHO PUT CHILDREN IN
CAGES.
>> Laura: ME BECAUSE THE MEDIA
PEOPLE LIKE YOU LIED, JEFF.
JOINING ME NOW IS LAURA LOGAN,
FORMER CBS REPORTER, 60 MINUTES
CORRESPONDENCE, REPORTED ALL
OVER THE WORLD ABOUT REALLY,
REALLY COUPLE GATED ISSUES.
IN A FAIR FASHION.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
ON THIS ISSUE OF IMMIGRATION,
SOMETHING THAT I'VE BEEN
REPORTING ON FOR 20 YEARS, ALL
THE CHANGES, ALL THE STRESSES ON
THE BORDER.
BUT REPORTERS ARE BASICALLY NOW
JUST ADVOCATES FOR THEIR OWN
SELF-CREATED NGO.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> LAURA, THERE ARE FEW
JOURNALISTIC QUESTIONS THAT I
WOULD WANT TO ASK IF I WAS
REPORTING ON THIS, WHICH IS,
WHERE DOES THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION WITH THE CHILDREN
THAT THEY DETAINED?
THEY ALSO PUT THEM IN PRISON,
RIGHT?
HOW DO I KNOW THIS?
IS A REPORT OF HER 60 MINUTES, I
WAS APPROACHED BY UNICEF.
I HAD MEETINGS WITH THEM ABOUT
DOING A STORY.
I WAS SO CONCERNED ABOUT THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN IN DETENTION
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION,
THEY ASKED 60 MINUTES TO LOOK
INTO DOING A STORY ON IT.
THIS WASN'T THE FIRST TIME IT'S
HAPPENED.
IT'S NOT BEING TREATED THE SAME.
ANYTIME THERE IS NOT A
CONSISTENT STANDARD AND
REPORTING, THAT IS A RED FLAG TO
JOURNALISTS.
>> Laura: LARA, THE ROOT
CAUSES OF THIS ALSO NOT BEING
COVERED, WHY THIS IS HAPPENING,
WHY IS THIS FLOW INTO THE
COUNTRY, WHY THE CARAVANS.
NONE OF THAT IS REALLY BEING
LOOKED AT.
EVERYONE IS EMPATHIZING WITH THE
POOR FAMILIES, AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT, BUT THAT IS NOT REAL
EMPATHIZING -- IT'S NOT REALLY
REPORTING.
IS EMPHASIZING.
IT'S DIFFERENT.
I WANT TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THE PRESIDENT'S DECISION TO SKIP
THE ANNUAL WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENTS DINNER, THIRD
YEAR IN A ROW NOW.
WHAT ABOUT THAT?
HE WILL HOLD A RALLY INSTEAD.
>> WHY WOULD THE PRESIDENT WANT
TO GO TO A DINNER, WHICH IS FULL
OF A ROOM FULL OF PEOPLE THAT
HAVE MADE IT CLEAR THAT MANY OF
WHOM HAVE MADE IT CLEAR THAT
THEY WANT HIM REMOVED FROM
OFFICE?
THEY DON'T JUST HATE HIM, THEY
SEE HIM AS UNFIT, AND MAY HAVE
MADE -- THIS IS NOT A GENERAL
WAY STREET.
IF THE PRESIDENT IS ALLOWED TO
CRITICIZE DONALD TRUMP, THEN WHY
CRITICIZE DONALD TRUMP, THEN WHI
CRITICIZE DONALD TRUMP, THEN WHN
CRITICIZE DONALD TRUMP, THEN WHT
CRITICIZE DONALD TRUMP, THEN WHH
CRITICIZE DONALD TRUMP, THEN WHE
CRITICIZE DONALD TRUMP, THEN WHA
CRITICIZE DONALD TRUMP, THEN WHL
CRITICIZE DONALD TRUMP, THEN WHW
CRITICIZE DONALD TRUMP, THEN WHD
CRITICIZE DONALD TRUMP, THEN WHT
CRITICIZE DONALD TRUMP, THEN WHO
CRITICIZE THE PRESS?
THAT IS THE WAY I LOOK AT THIS.
THIS IS ABOUT WITH THE
FIRST AMENDMENT IS ABOUT, AND
THIS IS ABOUT EVERYBODY'S
RIGHTS.
SO WOULD YOU GO TO A DINNER WITH
A BUNCH OF PEOPLE WHO MADE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT THEY WERE YOUR
ENEMIES?
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR HIM.
IT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE THE
COVERAGE.
I SKIPPED THE DINNER FOR THE
PAST FEW YEARS BECAUSE IT
BECOMES VERY PARTISAN AFFAIRS.
THEY MAKE A LOT OF PEOPLE
UNCOMFORTABLE.
THEY ARE NOT WHAT THEY USED TO
BE.
JOURNALISTS AND JOURNALISTIC
ORGANIZATIONS IN THIS COUNTRY
NEED TO STAND UP AND GO BACK TO
WHAT WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE AT
OUR CORE.
IF THEY WANT TO BE CRITICAL OF
THE PRESIDENT, WHICH IS PART OF
OUR RESPONSIBILITY AND DUTY AS
JOURNALISTS, THEN THEY DON'T GET
TO WEEP ABOUT IT WHEN HE'S
CRITICAL IN RETURN.
THIS IS VERY CONSISTENT WITH
DONALD TRUMP AS THE LEADER.
IT'S A VERY BOLD MOVE.
HE DOESN'T CARE THAT HE IS NOT
BEING --
>> Laura: I LOVE IT.